an outpouring of grief for a five-time
sporting champion inside the Staples
Center in Los Angeles home to the team
Kobe Bryant played for for 20 years
Lakers stars paid tribute in an
emotional pregame ceremony it's the
team's first game since the helicopter
crash that killed Kobe Bryant his
daughter Gianna
and seven others a week ago it's emerged
that the helicopter involved was not
licensed to fly unless the pilot could
see clearly due to the company's
licensing conditions it came down in
foggy weather NBA star LeBron James who
spoke to Bryant the morning before he
died paid tribute to the man he
considered not just a friend but a
brother I want to my teammates to
continue his legacy not only for this
year where as long as we could play the
game of basketball that we love because
that's what Kobe Bryant law jerseys worn
by Bryant and his daughter were draped
over the empty seats they were sat in
just under a month ago but beyond the
basketball courts where he made his name
fans continue to gather across the
country to honor their hero 20 years
since he came into the league and I just
love him and I just want to thank him
for everything he has done for us here
in LA look at all these people here
every size shape color what he did has
transcended and has joined so many
people the helicopter company has
grounded all flights as the
investigation into Brian's death
continues Johnny Longden Sky News